Rei Ohashi was immersed in her hobby of gaming that day
[Music] Are you making fun of me? Leiteira Claire-sama I
love Claire-sama Are you making fun of me? You
're a funny girl.
[Music]
Reincarnated in the world of maiden games.  My guess is that
Claire, the villainess, is
ignoring França.
[Music]
How can she remain calm when she's being so mean to you? Claire-
san,
don't make
fun of her either.As a roommate, I'll warn you,
Claire.
[Music] You don't care about
that commoner, but please
leave it to us, Claire. From now on, we won't
replace that commoner.
I'll make
sure to subjugate that commoner.  I'll let you do it. It
's wonderful. You're getting
your hands dirty, young
lady.
[Music] Please
step harder. I'm being
scolded.
Security should remain calm and do their job. My
recommendation is the villainess.
Study abroad broadcast begins
[Music]  ]